la vie reprend reprend lentement son
cours dans les rues de kiev les voitures
commencent à circuler depuis quelques
jours les habitants reviennent on estime
qu'au plus fort des bombardements ils
étaient encore 1 million en ville il
sera aujourd'hui entre 1 et 2 millions
difficile de savoir les commerces
rouvrent progressivement environ un
tiers des commerces et réouvert alors il
ya toujours de grandes difficultés
d'approvisionnement pour acheminer les
produits de première nécessité sur kiev
le peu de restaurants ouverts par
exemple manquent souvent de nourriture
le pétrole est toujours rationner les
retraits d'argent sont toujours limités
mais effectivement kiev retrouvent un
semblant de vie normale mais en même
temps les gens ici continue à avoir peur
ils ont peur et bien que la ville soit à
nouveau bombardée et assez massivement
d'ailleurs lorsque les russes
commenceront la grande bataille pour
l'est de l'ukraine pour le contrôle du
donbass et le gouvernement ukrainien
estime que désormais les troupes russes
ont pratiquement fini de de se
reconcentrer à la frontière avec l'est
de l'ukraine et que cette bataille est
désormais imminente